am i gonna get in round one
who's in there
250 at the moment
this is a um
this player has been
playing many
many many times now nice to see
for the team
good player
all right good luck
have some fun here try and set a a
personal
goal and maybe uh
see how it goes
streamers battle
all right
zero
round one oh
queen anne's revenge is gonna get
revenge
okay
i like this line
i think best is 94.
that usually gives me the most problems
i'm gonna i'm gonna take straight away
and
after that move
i'll go with this one
i think normally i tat i capture on d5
straight away
yeah
bishop f5 bishop d3
let's see how the center
shapes up
here i guess i could force the issue a
little bit
i'll go here threaten to take and go
here
and after this i have a file
bishop here
no bishop there
so my bishop's unprotected but
can it be taken advantage of
what if i go
here
i don't want to budge just yet with my
bishop stopping knight a5
i i don't like that my bishop's hanging
my id here is any bishop move other than
this square i could take on c6
and then hop in
so bishop h3 might be nearby
you've got a point man
am i in trouble
do i have to play night here i don't
want to have to do that
what if i go here
i'm already in the think tank
maybe best
to get out of bishop h6
bishop h3 now bishop h3 will still be
played
you dummy
oh
all right i guess we're gonna go here
wow i invested way too much time on that
last move
uh i didn't want to have to pull my
knight away from f3 i want to have
direct sight of g2 though maybe it's not
so bad
it's still a little still a little
nervous because this guy's unprotected
so until i get some pieces on some clean
squares like this guy here maybe the
knight on c4
yeah
don't hurt me man
okay it's clearly ready to hurt me
can't let you hurt me
just want to take here
bishop there you say
this will go here
i could have considered that now the
night goes here
i'm gonna have a jumpy night soon
i don't know that's an i'm not sure what
to do move
a5 knight b4 i'm giving up
i don't like my knight
all right that one
let's try this
it's risky
oh i have a four
i think i was ready to push and then
there would be some trick knight takes
here rook here
so they should be winning but the time
centralized
keep the knight under control
i said keep the knight under control i'm
giving back the exchange here
all right
the wheels are in motion
giving up a pawn but i'd have a passer
here let's keep going with this
i need a flight square
queen here would have been better maybe
not the cleanest technique
far from clean technique here
far from cleantech oh my goodness i just
dropped a rook
oh that was disgusting
oh
that was definitely disgusting
ah
sneaky
the revenge
oh
i dropped a r i dropped both of my rooks
oh man
okay miro
i guess miro had a tough first round i'm
guessing
ah
man
up a clean exchange what kind of garbage
technique was that
that was a lot of garbage technique i'd
say
ah and i had plenty of time
man
and now i'm i'm playing terrible in this
game here
all right let's play in the center
all right we're going to have mass
exchanges i guess
try and get back on the horse
i think i've equalized
can i be can i be happy
ah just king takes bishop that was
horrible
chopperoni and jumped the knight into e5
i might have to play with an isolated
pawn
it's not that big of a deal though
um tell you what let's go here i like
that i have a check if they exchange and
try a knight jump
oh the knight could go here though
can i get away taking this pawn
maybe
probably not
yeah night there
tell you what i'll go here i'll let the
rook enter
i'm not afraid
should i be
i could get one rook off
king here
i don't think i want to exchange both
rooks
i only expected rook there but this is a
good one too
yeah because
they have tricks knight f5 i have a
clock edge
that's about it
objectively it should be even
still in a pin but their knight is under
control for the moment i have this if it
tries to reroute
that one so let's go here this was my
idea
if the rook initial if the rook
initially went there
now it's not as comfortable
probably end up having to go back
i want to be able to flush the knight
away and then get a check in
or maybe even cut the rooks off
yeah so they withdraw a rook so now i
just want to get
one rook off
not both i mean i could go with both and
it's probably even but i'm gonna
try and play for more
play with the rookie on board
i like my king position
time to drive the night away
let's go here first
all right now
now i think i really should do this
the knight's gonna jump in here
huh
all right i didn't see that in between
her hopefully the rook and pawn ending
is all right oh wait a second
in-betweeners i get to take a pawn with
check
that wins the game
king and pawn ending well it's still not
clear
get this push in
yeah that'll be the way
i should have time
i should have time
this is a long road ahead to get a
passer on the queen side
threatening to take and one this guy or
this guy will be passed so i think best
is here but then i
yeah i have a passer now
and next up is
i have to be a little careful here
to be a little careful
i think this gives me the uh
all right i think i should bolt soon
it's still a little delicate
i'll run now
hmm
wait here
king takes pawn here push
here
push here
they have to push the pawn again
i get their pawn
they're in a box
hmm they had stalemate tricks if i
didn't do that
tricky man
oh that was a little more tricky than i
would have expected there
with the uh that king and pawn ending
holy smokes
this guy's cruising 11 points
how do you have 11 points already
wow
way to go keep it up
i got two
all right thomas style i haven't been
looking what teams i've been playing oh
i got the bishop
this is team chigalko and friends
all right
break up the duo
i'll plant that guy there i have support
i'll take with the queen
i do not mind seeing a queen exchange
i'll work on getting this guy activated
later
king safety is all i want not asking for
much
maybe i go queen side
now
i'll go kingside
open files
you take me approach
this guy's toast
one way or the other
take them
all right
i am defending the rook so
we'll go here
um
let's get a flight square in there
step up oh i could take the knight too
should probably take the knight next
time
these bishops are going to be killers
the rook is now restricted
don't go too far
went too far
all right yeah they just uh they dropped
that bishop there on b4
chess
blondinka
wfm
for team jagalco
and friends
all right are we gonna have a gruntfeld
king's indian defense
all right i like the space invader
i'll go for that
i think this is the correct approach
to immediately hunt the bishop
and i'm going to go with g4
have some experience with this structure
it's easy to go wrong as black
if i could get this guy up to h5 it's uh
it's usually some some slow death type
position
but there is action in the center here
clearly
and the plan
for me should be
what to first give a capture
i'm gonna go with this one
and then this one which is
a little scary but
i'm gonna do it
i just have to take extra care now
over the dark squares it's not easy
all right that one i think i want to
start
i don't care if the bishop goes there
come to think of it
if i do this then this maneuver stings
so i think i want to watch over
g3
be a little careful i would
like to see a light square bishop
exchange
how do i pull that off though
i think i want to start with this one
and then maybe a push
so i'm really tempted to we have a push
right now
i'll do it like this
so if this i have this and then that
maybe or a capture in the file
all right
let's put uh
let's try for this maneuver
am i really gaining a whole lot by doing
this i'm not putting this knight here
because i'm i'm anticipating this and i
think i want to fall back
that's a nice maneuver
i'll still i'll go here
i'm not sure what my follow-up is going
to be
i don't like this because the rook gets
this square
i don't have this move because my knight
will be dead
put my queen here maybe maybe this
let's try this and then here to here
am i getting anywhere with this maneuver
all right i think i might now
try this one maybe
a positional struggle
knight here
want the d5 square that knight is pretty
good though
queen is way too active
that maneuver by the knight to d6 is
great
yeah i'm not sure what to do either
um
all right i think i need to get this i
need to be able to push this pawn
okay
wait don't i have this one
to take the rook and then take the
bishop i guess is the best try
i have this check
soon
gotta go fast
yikes
almost gonna get mated
too tough man too tough
that was way too positional
um
it was only in time pressure that it
went
it went south
for my opponent
queen in the corner
got to a point where
my opponent didn't know what to do and
neither did i we were just making moves
all right some gambit i'll try to hang
on and maybe it's uncomfortable to
regain it for a little bit
okay this one
so now they're all right with an isolani
okay i'm getting
i'm getting tricked that's what's
happening
that's what's happening
i fell for a trick
fancy
fancy fancy this one within this one
alrighty
well
what can i do about that
am i just busted
here i don't know
i just don't know
bishop there
i should be able to castle i might have
to give up another pawn
i don't know bishop d6 castle king said
oh
you got that
one you got that one do you
what if i don't take
i'm going to say
let's not take
[Laughter]
that night is going to be pretty
dangerous so
yeah
take with the king
no
i have this covered
is the worst in the past
i might be a pest
should i be a pest
let's get castled
i don't think i want that pawn oh i want
the pawn with the knight
there we go i was only looking at this
one
tunnel vision
this is the way this is the monster
five i'm down upon i'll be getting that
one back i like my development
bishop pair
chop chop is the plan
i have maybe some tricks here
a night jump into this square is
probably a good idea
and if that
okay that one
that one suppose i go here
maybe go there
tricky tricky
let's start with that
and then
all right let's go with this one
maybe up a pawn i think
but it's a it's a half dead pawn
and knight here do i really want to take
that and give up this guy
i have a skewer maybe
bishop here if they yeah
bishop here night here is scary i might
need to
move my king immediately all right so
this one am i not getting uh
i'm not getting a an exchange here
pac-man so even if they go g3 could take
the queen
evening out on the clock
fought my way back out of that scary
beginning
i feel like i did uh walk right into a
trap there
they were ripping off those earlier
moves
there's something better than that
i'll babysit this pawn for a minute
just for a minute
all right let's
let's offer a queen exchange
let's see go hunting for the apon if
they take my a pawn
how about we defend everything
queen has a responsibility let's push
they could go to either square
let's push if they take the pawn they're
in a pin
try and drive the night away i gotta go
faster
a little faster
queen's in a good spot
ready to undermine the night
as soon as it's not defended by the
queen
and get the night now
tricky night
i could have captured the pawn there
speedy
speedy we're in second we're in second
by 27
who's uh who's fighting for us 25 fm
opponent or an fm opponent fm
team member 25 with fire
oh
you're cruising man
go go go
all right serlin i didn't see this one
on the top
holy smoke sirlin
serlin is cruising
all right the hungarian spy is there
so we got another nimzo indian i played
this in round two against that miro gm
i didn't like how the beginning went
maybe it was all right
let's castle
let's try a different structure in this
one
i am prepared
to give up my dark square bishop
um
let's let's hang on to this night post
for
for just a hair
and be a reinforcer
there we go
could be challenged further all right
they're they're ready to do something uh
fancy
with g4 maybe
that's what that tells me uh although it
could be just a defensive move right
they might not want to see now it's it's
definitely aggression
you have some aggressive intentions
don't you
yupper
well
let's go here and maybe we make them
think a little bit more about weakening
this diagonal
that night will be hanging
this is the scariest move the the number
one move to consider for sure opposite
sides castling i don't want this line
easily
opened up right towards my king so they
they're ducking the darks the knight for
bishop exchange
i could think about peeling open this
file i should probably go for this one
right now or could i go upon grabbing
take here and then take here
i'm gonna do that
yeah i'm gonna take that pawn even
though i'm opening up a line
i like the grip that i have over the
light squares
all right i should maybe jump in first
and then take
i'll do that one
and then take
now play where let's go
no
right here
maybe i push
my knight's gonna get kicked away
let's play in the center
file back to f6
they have a file
i have a pawn
ready to take now
okay
let's centralize
their bishop is awesome
and their clock is awesome too i'd like
to be able to shut down the bishop but
i'm not seeing a great way to do that
all right maybe this one i'm able to
sneak in now
because this i could take here and i
have that square
and if this i have that
bishop here i have c5
if they take here i'm covering the b4
square
also there's this as a possibility if my
knight is on d5
important i don't let this guy spring to
life
oh
well done
i go with this one
giving up the exchange if they want it
they're going to return they're not
returning
i should probably run with this
i want to jump in here but this is
this is going to hurt i want a square
for my knight
my clock oh that's the worst part
they have so many good options here
maybe it was a bad idea to take on g2
i think i probably need to play g6 maybe
i should have done that because instead
of running with this guy first
yep they still have that one
wow
don't hurt me man
wow
oh i could take here and i can take
there
time
oh they missed
holy smokes can't breathe
whoo
man
they had so much pressure on me the
whole game i'm not taking that g pawn
again
who cares about that g-pun
you have flooded with two
two major pieces breathing down my neck
combined with that bishop
oh am i asking for trouble
try something else next time please
right here i have that one
all right
looking to build a center
be a little fancy
we'll feed keto i'm going to try and say
my bishop's uh
a monster
i could have maybe considered that one
let's do it now
and then try and preserve it
no just giving me it
i'll take it
and the simple approach is to take here
now let's maybe try and win a pawn
let's let's try and uh
create an accident here
like right here we have this one right
when upon with the sequence
just make some x's in the position
that's where
tactics are going to be
right boom boom boom
intersection squares
so with this fancy sequence in the end
i'm up a pawn
my light squares are weakened on the
king side but there aren't any
there aren't any great pieces
on black's end that could exploit these
light squares no knights no light square
bishops the rook isn't going to
the queen
is the only one
i have a pawn but black has control of
the only open file
let's uh
let's start with this one
make sure this base point is covered
queen here maybe i take there probably
take there
and from here maybe i get this guy up to
c5
i think i like this
i like that my queen can maybe pivot on
this square
okay she can't go here now
let's start with this one maybe hinting
at a a break
queen here and a break
okay the queen has gone
on the defensive
how about we try and poke around a
little bit
this one
i wouldn't mind going for this exchange
because my queen on g5 combined with
this h-pawn running up
is gonna
be a big problem
so even though this guy would turn past
they'd probably have to find a way to
get the queens off
not seeing a clear way to do that okay
they're
exchanging queens but now i'm up the
pawn and i get the file
this is the only try
to create a dent in my structure
i'm going to start with this so this guy
doesn't clamp down
improve my king of hair
continue
and let what about this
okay so now we have an entry point
look here i have that
rook here i'll probably still go here
freeze the freeze this pawn
okay
now we get a second pawn and my rook
remains active
who's this team dorina's party
got a second pawn we're not finished
though
you get some more it's the only base
point to watch over now
have this maybe if the rook isn't there
i had pressure on that one let's drive
the king back
and then
i guess we could still go on this
um
pawn hunting
we'll still go with this pawn hunting
approach
if this i'll probably just go away
is my rock gonna get stuck
and just in case my rook might get stuck
let's go over here
king f6 h4
yeah let's
let's go in this direction
now here there's this and then that
stopping entry
squares
stopping black from entering
all right back to tournament
we still have a little bit of a lead
there over kc's crew is in third
jagalko and friends running away with it
five 582 we're at 434
still an hour 20 to go
chess 2089 jagalko and friends oh the
game here
all right d4 i'm getting hit with a lot
of d4 games
let's try g6
enough of that nimzo indian
let's try this one
in this one
looking for a quick strike
d5
let's do it right away
all right this is my favorite piece
currently
it's not sarcasm either
i really do like this night
i'm a fan of that night
does a good job in stopping the central
expansion
what's the story with this guy
all right let's play
well the knight will go back
um
h6r all right let's go with h6
f5 it is
yeah
light square approach
i understand
you have a big square
no doubt
i should have played here first
and i was
i don't know
oh you know what i'm ready to do maybe
jump in here and then there
need to be able to challenge the night
all right
this is a good square
this this could uh
free up my bishop
should maybe consider that one
interesting approach
i get the knight on f4 all right
it's time to break
playing so fast
all right even if they
go there i i need i need to make a break
i'm gonna get killed
just a clean pawn i'm giving up
i need a tactic
and i'm not seeing any good tactic for
me
to try g4 and hope something happens
oh that's where i'm at hope chess
i can't even take that
this is a bad game
really bad clock position everything
about it
bad news
oh my goodness
that's what happens when you go way too
fast
they fell for a maintenance one
queen anything won
oh man
i didn't deserve to win that one
they were in full speed ahead just push
the passer
my first threat is my first threat
holy smokes
i'm going to play the lottery right
after this game right after this stream
lucky dog man
i threatened to make you won
i did not deserve to win that one
at all
yeah that that play on the queen side my
my king side pawn advances
silly town
yeah i think f5 just
gave them way too much that e4 square
and
they're awesome
all right so no d5
oh that was a mouse slipper i guess
no take backs
as i give the pawn right back
i'll go here
i'll go here
how about this one and then here
and
how do we move forward
let's do this
i have an idea
which is to maneuver this night and now
if the night goes here i have this
maneuver
i think it's harmonious
you got a space invader
let's challenge it right away
all right i'm taking the queen no i'll
take with the knight i want a
pre-prepared ops out of night
now we're going to look for
an f5 break
i may insist i should probably insist
it's not necessary
do a positional approach now let's let's
go with this
get the file
make sure this pawn doesn't move
all right
well if you're not going to
go over here i'm going to put this
knight on its favorite square
okay
and what's the plan
get to the h file i guess
they're prepared to hide
they're prepared to run with the king
suppose i
jump around a little bit
that one
my king will defend right
what if i put a little pressure there
i missed that
it's another fast player i should uh i
should move fast
giving up on the h file wanna
oh
they have a trick here
knight f5
still not clear
so i would have f6 as a follow-up
now now stuff is happening here
or maybe here
now let's get this guy going and then
this maneuver
let's hang and now we have this one
now there's trouble
the tri-rook
rook on this square
now there should be an accident
happening queen here
circling in
now it's a maintenance two
all right
um
we have about
23 just 21. 20 point edge over third
jagalko and friends
140 plus
thank you very much for gifting those 10
subs gk
appreciate that
zalakai thank you for the hundred bits
sanrayu thank you for the prime sub
sogo thank you for gifting a sub i'm
just seeing all these now
appreciate that
another d4
okay at least this is a little different
hyper accelerated
london
is that what we have
queen beat three c4 not winning a piece
but it's
definitely comfortable
i have the better queen here
and the better pawn presence
no issues for black
black is probably better
familiar maneuver with the light square
bishop
let's go here i like being able to go
here and have my rooks connected
i'm also opposite the queen i can't feel
too comfortable
may wanna
may wanna what
may wanna what
doesn't even sound like english may
wanna what
okay maybe i take here
let's bring the queen back
i'm just not sure
i'm gonna take like this
initially i was gonna go like that but i
end up getting caught in a crossfire
with these bishops they track down my
rook
that maneuver
killer
let me let me get rid of the piece
that's in my house
all right
so we have this simplified position rook
specific
flight square and stop f5 they're
offering a draw i'm i'm gonna play on
so the plan here is
what
gonna go all in
well
let's start with this one
get off the file watch out for some
breaks
all right there's a pin
[Music]
rook c4
the d file i could stop the d file from
opening up maybe i should have yeah
let's let's go for this i don't want to
see this
the g file can open up though
the rook is very good
my rook on e4 should be pretty good i
want to stop the entry points as a super
committal move stop the break but i
exposed my king
i place some
restrictions on my queen when i do this
she has some defensive task
somehow in the dark squares the rook
entering
now probably towards the center keep one
pawn island
seems healthy
um
let's get this one in
rookie eight
huh
it's threatening to capture two they
were out of that pin
this one's in the crosshairs
ready to push too
maybe we enter here
my rook is really active
should be i think it's a one king or a
rook and pawn ending
improve my k now let's do this i want to
hide here maybe
all right
guard my base point
one king and pawn ending
plenty of time
no stalemates
okay are we at 580 oh we have a
44 point cushion over second still an
hour to go we're holding on to that
number two spot
these guys are
cruising dr x stranger
pack leader oh i just see the cable box
there's a familiar
player for the team nice to see
the very
sharp cable box in there
had a really good game
the cable box did against
uh mamidyarov in the one streamer's
battle
bishop here
um
all right
i'm preparing i can't stop that break so
just have to be in a position i guess to
maybe blockade
i think this knight is a little clumsy
on b4
really wasn't
that sequence there wasn't a
great inconvenience for me
so i have this jump or that jump
or none of the above jumps
um
this one knight into here
i could go here
let's do this for starters
okay now now it's tough to
well let's start with this one
um
okay
let's continue
um
let's defend the night
threaten me
i was being a sneaky guy
all right let's get some air for my king
they're going
fast they're making nothing moves those
last few
i can make progress from this position
dark squares man
dark squares
my knight has a
monster grip on the dark squares
mating two threat
let's do it like that
oh
wow
wow this went this went south really
fast
i have to go into time burner mode after
that excellent position
crazy
foreign after that kind of grip over the
dark squares
my goodness no stalemates right
should never
should never happen like that
it should be mate or me winning a a
queen or a rook or something
why
why why does it have to go down to
a position where i'm losing there in the
ending
probably
okay
under an hour to go
ah dark square bishop exchange likely
and that was a berserk game too
i'm not sure what exactly was
accomplished with that maneuver by the
bishop
gear up for e4
let's put this in first
all right let's get this in now yeah
while this is a little bit vulnerable in
fact
if i go here
i'm going to try this one
if i remove the knight i have at least
this
generating a threat
okay
so now let's let's key in on this uh
this square this bishop's dead
for the moment
good organization
um i could play bishop d let's let's get
some space
this seems useful
seems like they're asking for some
trouble with that move
start with this maybe this maneuver
it may get
punch here on c1 queen f3 and f7 there
might be an accident here
all right
i think
i think i want to go here
yeah
oh they have a night jump here
but still this guy struggling piece
let's go with this one
more active queen goodnight space they
have one one good square
i could give this check right now
let's do this though stop knight f4
if the knight moves i rook out for
possible forks
this the king can't take
let's stop the night move
probably gonna do that
that one
try this
i do have a lot of stuff on this square
threatening to take and go here
very caveman-like idea but
not sure how this one's working out
scary
all right
all right i'm going to try this
oh i almost just blundered
yeah this is not this was not the best
way
they double rooks bishop d7 i don't have
any time though
king position
whew
felt like it should have been over in
the middle game
somewheres
okay
still have a little bit of a cushion
52 minutes remaining why be mad
okay
we'll go for this
setup
solid
i don't like my queen move
gonna blast open the center aren't you
i think i could afford to give this
square up to the knight that
unleashes everything
if i tried some pin there's a counter
pin
on protected bishop
so
maybe now i take you know i'm gonna i'm
gonna be in some
i have some problems either way
centralized first maybe they take and i
have a
you go for the exchange it's still not
clear
i don't even know if i would go for that
let's try this now
and then here
this one possibly i could have
considered that a move earlier
then a check so this is a threat right
now
or maybe that
where's the queen go exactly
i'm gonna end up with a half dead pawn
or completely dead
this might be one of the completely dead
ones
how to whip up some trouble
not sure how to do that
it's a good move
that's a very good move
all right i don't see what to do
do i have to really do this
ugh does this look ugly
it's very ugly
flush the queen away maybe
i need a square man
need a square
can't take with the knight
unless i want to get mated
i don't like having the isolated pawn
but what can you do
they could
track down upon i get to the seventh
rank i don't know if it's
all that great we're gonna find out
i get that pawn back
think i'm doing all right
converging on f2
at some point
after a capture here
i have the check covered to go hunting
the a-pawn after 8-3
the knight doesn't have
a great pick of squares right now this
is the only one
evening out on the clock now
they're in the tank
night there let's start by
taking a pawn i guess
and i don't think i have anything better
this is a draw objectively
oh for a draw
let's see
these doubled these
the messed up king side yeah draw
the messed up
king side structure is a non-factor in
that simplified ending
yeah that uh that queen b1 move was too
too fancy
it's a different story if they if they
don't break with d5
in in in a different position if a
slower position then it's
maybe all right to do that
maybe
but their uh their follow-up was good
all right so
[Applause]
i'm not yet committing my d-pawn
i guess until now
got to play with this
i'm not i don't want to take with the
pawn
i'm going to take with the knight so i
could
try and get rid of their their best
piece
their light square bishop is their best
piece
knifing right down
in my camp
let's try this
strike some imbalance in the position
and i have this square still
all right i don't know how great an
inconvenience it will be
well we could we could what if i take
here and then go after this pawn though
i'm gonna give up that strong looking
knight
and go hunting night here no not there
so if i take knight takes here check
here here
and i get this one i don't like that
i've given up the file though
what if i begin with the push
save my pawn
or not push at all
i'm not going to push it all
i have i have other ways to uh
like if rook here i have this one i
think
threatening this and that
i have i have many ways to hit this pawn
so if i go with this right now
i think there's a big problem
any rook move here i could play bishop
takes knight
yeah this should be excellent i'm
anticipating the win of a pawn i like
that i don't have any back rank issues
there's something this may tip in my
favor
some back rank weakness
against black so
i could take the knight
straight away
i'll go for that
yeah i'll go for
that guess here
cut out this square from the night
still
here here it's under control if it gets
to this square
i just want to get to the seventh now
or eighth down on the clock though
no good pawn breaks that i'm seeing for
black so it's about peace peace
improvements
yeah i'm not thinking about any pond
moves right now
i want i want two pigs
on the seventh that's all i'm looking
for oh this is a mate threat
see that
i'm gonna go here it's ugly
double isolated pawns but i don't want
the knight to get f5
oh the night gets there though
this was
foolish
maybe it's all right though getting to
the seventh or am i
wow all right let's start here i have
this square covered
yep
all right let's run it like this
wow
they're cruising man
they're definitely cruising
why why was i going after
why not go after this pawn
my clock man my clock
my king is hiding
at the pin
whoo okay
42 minutes remaining
a non-gamers in first for the team with
60 points they must be
wow they're in second place overall how
many players nearly three thousand
they're in second
very strong run
sergey zagalko and friends i'm getting
berserked
now feeling
up for uh
a berserk back here
they're giving me some time to consider
i've already considered though
not feeling up
for a berserk
i'll be five don't let this happen too
easily and can i not win this pawn
there's knight b6
all right
all right what about
i go for the night maneuver now
[Music]
we're offering a draw
am i getting anywhere with this approach
i don't know
i don't think so
yeah
you got a point
there what if i dance a little bit
like b6 into c4
there we go
just dance
knight on c4 put some serious pressure
on d6
i play with e4
i don't know i don't know let me start
with this one
i think i want to get rid of their
bishop
we start with this
that one
it's a good move
all right let's try this
let's go with this one
yeah
all right i'm gonna be down to b-pawn
maybe
but then maybe i get some play yeah
smart
smart decision
i don't want my king on h2
b4 nearby
let's get in b3 i don't want to see this
go
safe or square now for my king
i drive the knight away
baby step it
now probably this one
that they're not on this file anymore
let's go here if they push i have a nice
square on d4
stop to break with b6
maybe i win this pawn next
not straight away
i have to watch out too i have to drive
this this night away probably
in order to make progress
capture away here
now's the time
we'll go with a we'll keep my queen
right where she's at
and look for this break next
where's that night going
doesn't know
does not know where it wants to go
take this
in the night
all right
trying to recall
the world championship here
clean guard some nice squares
time
sneaky opponent
time
oh my goodness they were going way too
fast
oh i spent so much time trying to find a
good queen spot to stop any possible
perpetual checks
a draw out of gas no time in the tank 36
minutes remaining
okay
let's try
let's try e5
bishop opening
gonna go after that guy
all right
i'm not up to speed with this
but i'm still gonna give it a go
yup
looks crazy
it's definitely looking crazy
let's see though
peace play
traxler
the wilkes-barre gambit
so what's my plan
do something with these guys
all right let's start with this one or
how do i complete my development
hmm
i think i should probably drive that
knight back
gotta watch out for d4
that could definitely hurt
something like that
maybe
i like that i don't have to worry about
a night getting in here all right
interesting
so if i take here
chop on d4 first
i chop here first
queen takes i get this
big moment
okay get the pawn back but my king is
still in the center
they may just push
get this guy
queen on e queen on e6 i think should be
decent
let's step up here
seems healthy
wouldn't mind a queen exchange the
structure is all right for an ending
pawn controls the night
so queen g4 possibly
merceka and friends
my opponents playing
um
i think i'm going to
get here while i can i think
bishop there
i'll take
i don't want to drop this pawn
okay they're going conservative
f4 would be more
much more aggressive
let's come back over
and watch the time this might be a
speedy opponent
have this covered
queen on f7
rooks on the e and f files
allowing a really good break there
rook on e5 then i'm ready to take here
there might be some tricks with rook
takes pawn
start with this one
take towards the center i want to drop
here it's a healthy structure
i don't think the rook belongs there
anymore
24 seconds oh boy
crawling up into a ball here
fancy man
had that covered
time burners
playing with fire with this last move
no oh
[Laughter]
oh man
oh they got that discovery check
okay under 30 to go
um still in second
cable box cruising man
66
team bruvus
all right no
no grunfeld
a battle over d4
let's go here
i think i should do what should i push
i think i'm gonna push
and now
let's try this
this knight here i think is
should i take
yeah i think i should take
and then play my knight here
i don't want to end up with the
having to babysit the pawn on c4
could be hit
too many ways
now this square is a big big deal
big fight over c4 and so instead of
castles i think it's more important to
focus on the c4 square
though i think i should take a time out
for this maybe it's nice to have the
night here for a moment
let's get out of any discoveries
like in the last game
centralize
they could end up making a move like
this rook takes i have well there might
be some trick here
um
let me return
all right so now this is a possibility
let's go here c4
when is the question
when oh what about this and then here
i'm going astray
worthwhile to put the queen
on h6 we'll give it a shot
not sure about this
yeah
that one
way down on the clock
not really getting anywhere
losing this pawn
this was a silly approach
yep
they didn't take that pawn straight away
gotta try and get to f2
fancy
fancy fancy
they might have been too fancy though
seconds for me
i could take the knight
wow
i'm gonna have to
try and call her bluff there
only way for the queen enters on h3
don't hurt me
11 seconds
they have that check
yikes
oh i gotta run for the hills
i don't know what to do
i can't make a break
no time
ah
way too much pressure on me
ate up all my clock
all right we still have a lead kept
about a 40 point lead
might be taken second
a first first time for confetti maybe
80 point lead
those two are cruising cable box and a
non-gamer
having a great
a great showing
mr fernandez let's try sicilian
hello nifa in the chat
let's try neidorf
all right we enter
a not so
night orphy
position
or like a
french
let's take and then go here
should be about even
i don't know if i want to castle king
side just yet
they're ready to make a night move and
then
this
i'm gonna say this is all right i have
an f5 f6 break
i'll wait for their knight to move
though before f6
if they're gonna go for that
well i could take this pawn
but i think
i really i'm gonna experience some
problems if i do that so let's get this
break in allow my rook to help defend
some sixth rank squares
this could be a move
with the bishop takes h6 i may still do
this though
do i not win a pawn soon
rook f5
really trying to kill me here
you're really trying to kill me
okay
bishop f6
what about offer a queen exchange
offer queen exchange
night chop here there is no queen g6
queen takes pawn i should uh
what am i doing i'm forgetting the
knight could go here and the rook could
enter
oh
man
totally forgot about that
oh that was so foolish i'm getting
killed with these four pieces
the queen exchange is not a guarantee
do i have to play king h7 if i take the
knight rook check
rook check i'm dead i gotta walk into
this
right here here
clean h8 i should be able to weasel away
if they
go for more i think they have to go for
this perpetual
shortest game of the the battle right
there
i don't know
i think that was the correct end result
all right 20 minutes to go a non-gamer
in first now for a 72-70 and then a huge
drop off 50. where am i at
46.
i'm lucky
there i am 45
candidate master opponent playing for
diana's darlings
french or what am i saying a french a
dutch
let's put this guy here
and this guy here
all right i'll
chop well i don't want to help that
queen
develop so easily so
threatening this
do i not win this pawn now
in some pin i could break it though
now i have this pawn if i want it
and chop there
i think i do want to take here and then
i could follow up with
rook c1
queen exchange can't be avoided
so i'm up a pawn
and
what truck do i want to go with
probably this one
oh there's they're ready for a trick
here
that bishop man
fancy
fancy bishop
all right so let's start with this
i have this move to stop knight b4
i think i want to do this i don't want
them to be able to
quickly enter my position so
um
i may have to be all right with that
let's go here
i'm anticipating pressure on f2
i still need a couple consolidating
moves
i feel
i want to do that initially
so night before i'm prepared to
give it a boot and then
i don't know then get to the c file
if there's ever this capture i have a
path for my knight into e5
i'm glad they're thinking
16 minutes to go
w
yeah that's uh only the top 20 count for
the team total
opponent's really in the tank here
air down a pond trying to find a way to
whip up some trouble
i could sneak in this flight square
is it worthwhile
i'm gonna flick this move in
and now flight square
might be a little bit of an issue if i
get to their back rank
okay
what do we want to do here
i want to start with this
rook is entering
oh the knight can return here maybe
again with this trick
and this one
huh
all right
let's stop the knight and the rook from
getting here
now both of our knights are struggling
in this position
i'm up the i'm upon okay so now i get
the file
yeah this rook is clumsy
knight here i have
bishop here or again there's this trick
on d4 an unprotected piece
all right
there's still a trick
no i get out of the trick with a check
if they take here
that one this and then the capture
and i'm saving this guy so
let's insert the check
let's get out of any tricks
save this pawn
and now i'm ready for this
and then this maybe maybe maybe
okay
let's pin the night
can i get my night working soon
it's almost working
it's working
time though time time time
regarding this
yeah they missed that i was on that one
okay
up 40 still
1100 first maybe we could get to a
thousand
maybe final 13 minutes couple more games
all right let's go it's d4
this is another
competitor
for diana's darlings
let's try the classical
names oh indian classical
i'll take
gonna kill me
c5
it's probably the most testing
i'll take
yeah i think i missed my chance there
to get the dark square bishop back
i don't like how i'm playing this
they are uh at least equal i'd say black
is better now
very good bishop
and try and get the light square bishops
off
i don't know if it was really a
i'm accomplishing a whole lot
by inserting the check there and then
bishop f5
i don't know where do my rooks belong
we'll put one here in case they form a
battery i could maybe run
if this knight isn't around anymore
it could be challenged
i probably have to go with this minority
bring it to a point where b5 is a blink
away
and then
and then think for a little bit
all right i'll take
queen takes pawn is not a i'm covered in
many ways
queen g4 is what i want
knight c5 maybe we enter an ending if i
have a pawn on c5 i'm playing for
something possibly
uh i should probably carry on with this
break my knight's gonna have to find a
different home
queen can't go too far okay now it's
starting to get a little concerning
the old rook lifter
yikes
preparing for a break
i don't like doing it like this but i
may have to
all right now there isn't this anymore
look here there's queen takes pawn
yep
very delicate
why am i always getting attacked with
everything
that
one perpetual i got away with there
yeah they're just bringing
all the heat
at me here
this may already be here
wow
nice calcium calculation on my part
there
well done
be a miracle if i get out of this one
you take here that's one way to do it
under a minute though it's bullet time
how's the bullet rating
2400
he got a hungry pond
two rooks versus a queen this pond is
still living
he's still alive
they're really in the tank
time to take a pawn
yeah i didn't consider that
oh boy
i have to do this
oh they're on that
okay knight
your job
is to defend upon
fortress
careful now
my knight should be pretty good right
here
master defender
i don't know where i want to go
holy smokes barely
we're up 25.
oh man
they're right on our heels
29
one game to go
second place confetti maybe
think we're gonna break into a thousand
nine ninety five okay
a berserker this one this one should
finish
now let me go here
all right i'll i'll initiate
what's the plan with this knight
get out of there
possible forks
we got king's side
so the file
have a
a jumpy night
all right this knight wants to be here
how do i make that happen
maybe like this
my bishop returns
let's stick around right here
and on c6
let's keep the knight out of this square
it's going to go for that one too
do i want the rocks on or off
let's go here first
maybe a fork
all right
if we go back here if this is ever a
thing
try and scare the queen away to a
different square
hmm
interesting
do i even want to take that pawn
probably need to get rid of that
it's not easy
not easy at all
wow i'm almost gonna get killed here
gotta jump around with the knight
am i tracking this guy down
they're not making it easy
on f2
just improve the night
one sneaky move
all right that one counts
i think we're taking it eight
second place
whoa
this one is not gonna count here
this final game
how many are in here
alright tiga
sergey jagalko and friends let's try
karo
to end
a draw offer
um
yeah i'll just play
okay
i was ready to go here first
kind of important to cover that square i
think
if i go here this could be a move
a little irritating
are they ready to go for that one
yeah this should be a decent defender
okay light square bishop exchange
do not mind seeing that
let's get this break in
and take with the knight not the bishop
i don't want a bishop exchange and then
this guy arriving here
all right
do i drive the knight away now maybe
this one and then c4
yeah
this guy is a monster
i think i'm winning this pawn
i might have to try that
threaten to sacrifice
it's the only move i'm fearing okay
could take there
and try and get this
let's see here there take queen takes
queen takes pawn they're gonna have a
perpetual
oh i could move i could move the knight
yeah let's do it like this put this
knight as a defender for my king and
threatening that
bishop there i could take and then rook
up and over
could have maybe even started with this
and then played the knight here
that would have been cleaner you don't
even give this
this option to white
capture on h6
i think they have to go for it
even if it's objectively bad
you're not going for it
all right let's secure that
could have once more captured here and
then maybe played that
i'm still giving wide an opportunity
to chop there
to chop or not
i mean i think after a couple chops in
the night here
there's no queen g5 and queen f6's
nearby i could abandon trying to get
this pawn so i think now is the time to
if i take here pawn takes and then
there's a trick on f6 maybe
let's do it like this though pawn takes
i'll go like this
get out of the tricks on f6
take on this screw with the knight
or maybe even glue the knight in there
all right let's take like that
queen exchange i do not mind this knight
should be amazing on d6
battle is over i think we took second
but something ridiculous happened
queen a5
where are the tricks
this knight is pesky
i think i'm going to start with
giving that knight a kick
i'm just losing this pawn what am i
doing
okay
am i ready for a trick yet here and then
here
drive this night away
let's go with this one
a bit scary for sure
my rook and block
this was a really bad decision
i'm giving up that pawn
this stuff is scary too
that night is so dangerous
oh
made it way too easy
a draw in the end
facing a mating one okay
back to tournament
second place
whoa
a first time for confetti
sergey jagalko and friends taking first
1 230 points
it's really beefy
second place ten thousand forty eight
ten thousand oh my goodness
i only played two hours of chess and i'm
calling it ten thousand one thousand
forty eight
kc taking third one thousand eleven
all right
let's see route chess masters fourth
diana's darlings team bruvus
mursika and friends the big greek
a gad matures team dorina's party
and
the excellencies chess hobbits team
hushi
and papa see
all right
played
good games all
fun event uh let me see what the uh
team standings were
88 for a non-gamer
is that that's almost
that's gotta be close to first
finished third overall
didn't all up berserk it seems
95 berserk berserk
that's an amazing performance
um
i finished the cable box second there
with 79 i had 53.
debassi 53 as well
our top 20
43 plus
average score 17.
wow
good team results
very cool good games all
you